(Jim grunts)
-TORI: Nice.
-JIM: Our bushwack
has commenced!
We want to make
our camp more like home,
so we're going foraging
for wood and supplies
to build some furniture.
But our camp here
is situated on protected land,
so we need to hike
to a spot upstream
where the government allows
you to cut down dead trees
and, and live branches,
and basically source the wood
that we're gonna need.
And we're bringing
the canoe on this bushwack,
so we'll have a way
to bring all this wood
back to our campsite.
TORI: Oh God.
I think you're stuck, hon.
-JIM: That's a no.
-TORI (off screen):
Reverse to your left.
-Turn the back.
-JIM: Yeah, I'm just
gonna go straight here.
(grunting)
TORI:
Carrying the canoe is definitely
an awkward
and uncomfortable
thing to do,
with all the weight
on your shoulders,
but he, also, can
put it down at any moment.
I'm carrying both children,
each weigh 30 pounds,
so... basically, wearing
a 60-pound weighted vest,
and I cannot take it off
and put it down for a moment,
but... I think
I have the cuter job.
(heavy breathing)
I think this is our best bet.
(Jim grunting)
-Hi. There we go.
-(babbling)
That's wonderful. Good job.
I'm just noticing
how happy Wesley is,
and how much eye contact
he's been making with me.
And, um, eye contact
is something that he's not
always been so good at,
and... it's a big indicator
of some progression for him, so.
Hi. There it is.
Hi, sweetheart.
Yeah, I think this
is so good for him.
-JIM (off screen):
Whew! We made it.
-TORI: All right. Ooh.
(exhales)
Feel like I'm floating.
Look at Wes sitting
so high in the canoe there
on his elbows.
JIM: Come here, Wes.
TORI: He was so happy
pretty much the entire walk,
like, when he wasn't sleeping,
he was, like, super happy.
Also, just looking around
at his surroundings,
like, looking up at the trees.
JIM:
That's really good, eh?
It just goes to show that
it's even better for him to be
in the outdoors and in nature
-than your average person.
-TORI: Yeah.
JIM:
So, you know, just that--
I don't know,
just different surroundings
or whatever it is,
it seems to be working for him.
TORI:
It's fun to watch Hudson
interact with Wesley.
Hudson doesn't see
Wesley any differently
than he does Jim or I.
JIM: I feel like it's
definitely helped Wesley
just have
another person there
that kinda he can connect with,
even though his little brother
pulls his hair sometimes,
it doesn't matter.
-And I also think that...
-TORI: He bites.
JIM:
...that Hudson is
going to learn
so much more responsibility,
and, and be so much wiser
at such a young age
because of his
brother's challenges.
Judging by the way
that the kids are behaving
and how happy they are out here,
it's making me think
that, uh, you know,
maybe we get
a little property
in a place like this,
and build a little
wilderness home.
Even if there's
potentially a place of buying
-a remote property in there...
-TORI: Mm-hm.
-Right.
-JIM: ...it could be
a, a possible place
that we might consider
building an off-grid cabin,
and slowly, you know,
basically starting to make
that our home base
'til one day, maybe that's
our permanent residence,
who knows?
-TORI: That would be amazing.
-JIM: Ah, yeah.